c'était une annonce attendue celle sur
le scandale chlordécone aux antilles
hier depuis le morne rouge
emmanuel macron a reconnu la
responsabilité de l'état dans cette
affaire il a parlé de scandale
environnemental et de réparation des
idées ont été lancées en direction des
agriculteurs bonjour louis-félix
lauriane bonjour maître le secrétaire
général de la fdsea la fédération
départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles hier en fin de
journée en compagnie des jeunes
agriculteurs vous avez quand même bloqué
la route de didier devant la résidence
préfectorale pour dénoncer une forme de
mépris à votre égard oui tout à fait
parce que bon
déjà au début les syndicats les
représentants de la filière avec ronit
pas invités à discuter avec le président
donc nous avons fait savoir aux
autorités au préfet à la direction
actuelle et de la forêt qu'il était
inadmissible qu'un président vienne a
menti nick visite une exploitation
agricole et que le les représentants de
l'aviculture ne sera pas entendue alors
fait la magie cette rencontre soit en
préfecture la parole libérée pour
aborder des thèmes comme la retraite à
90 ans il n'y a pas eu
il n'y a pas eu d'autres conseillers du
président mais on a rencontré pourquoi
parce qu'on a bloqué ouais au début le
matin ils nous avaient proposé
conseiller et une autre équipe sur
montrouge pour discuter avec le
président et le matin on a un conseiller
qui se présentent et quand on vérifie
puisque bon jovi on allait en internet
on vérifie qui est ce monsieur on voit
que c'est un monsieur qui s'occupe de
l'ain
de l'éducation qui est responsable de
l'éducation
comment les agriculteurs peuvent
discuter avec quelqu'un qui est
responsable de l'éducation
donc on l'a remis à si gentiment et au
lieu de deux il lui a transmis un
message au président en lui disant que
les agriculteurs ont déjà pris les eaux
pour les a écoutés ont déjà pris le
français louis donc il sera seul
responsable des conséquences de ce qu'il
va faire
le recueil ne rencontra même hier soir
deux heures de rencontre pour parler de
la retraite la protection de la
production locale la réduction des
délais pour les indemnisations des
calamités agricoles encore la stabilité
des cadres réglementaires par exemple en
termes de protection de nos rivaux de
l'environnement est ce que vous êtes
rassurés ce matin mais précieux et si un
petit peu parce que mon on a rencontré
quand même monsieur
cassel ou quand elles général je me
souviens plus de son nom mais qui qui
qui avait quand même une maîtrise une
connaissance de notre département et on
a l'assurance que nos doléances ont
relayé auprès du président alors le
morne rouge et les annonces de la
présidence concernant le scandale
chlordécone état qui reconnaît en partie
serrée son service il parle de scandale
environnemental pain de réparation c'est
pas énorme pour vous mais il ya ya ya
déjà pas mal de financement en
martinique concernant le chlordécone le
rôle de claude économes en eau les culs
la wii au seul là ça allait de soi
on a toujours dit il faut quand même
cibler les dépenses sur la dépollution
sur aussi les l'indemnisation pourquoi
parce que celui qui est toujours en
ligne de mire
c'est l'agriculture celui qui est
toujours oublié c'est aussi
l'agriculture et ça je le répète pas
uniquement concernant chlordécone
on est souvent les productions on va
dire oui on va mettre 2 millions sur la
banane on va mettre 2 millions sur la
diversification
on va mettre 2 millions sur l'élevage
mais l'agriculteur lui même qui est en
tête de file
qu'est ce qu'on met en place pour
l'agriculture il n'y a pas eu des propos
rassurants de la part du président bien
sûr et remaniée les agriculteurs qui
vont lancer donnerai mes productions sur
sept à partir d'une carte de la mère
nous ce qu'on dit à chaque fois par
rapport à ces propos la transformer ces
propos là un acte transformer ses
propres mains at me l'ont dit quelle
feuille mais il met you toujours en
politique et caresse un politicien ils
disent toujours je vais faire oui ak il
a dit qu'il est le président différentes
c'est ce qu'il a
ils sont tous différents mais on a
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
depuis que je suis dans l'agriculture on
a les mêmes problèmes que ceux qui
étaient lettre il ya dix à vingt ans
avant moi les années futures exposée à
la molécule emmanuel mac ont dit qu'il
n'y a pas de preuve scientifique établi
que la présence de chlordécone dans le
corps puisse avoir un effet sur la santé
humaine
mais ils on peut quand même avancer sur
la question des maladies
professionnelles pour les personnes
exposées révision des tableaux des
maladies professionnelles dans quelques
jours est ce que c'est un bon pas là
également
mais c'est certainement un bon pas mais
moi de mon côté je vous rappelle que moi
aussi je suis pas un scientifique
je suis un agriculteur avant tout on est
il ya les agriculteurs et les pêcheurs
on est des professionnels
maintenant que chacun reste à sa place
que chacun respecte leur engagement
parce que tout aujourd'hui il ya quelque
chose qu'on a constaté des qui a une
approche des élections le quelques
collections que ce soit
il y à une flambée du chlordécone
on parle de chlordécone a à tort et à
travers par tous même les médias veille
de constater que la fdsea depuis
quelques mois n'a pas réagi pourquoi
parce que souvent c'est les approches
des élections tout le monde parle de
chlordécone sans même ma sélection la
chambre d'agriculture
il ya les options nationales culture il
ya les élections
e au niveau de l'europe tout le monde
parle de chlordécone
sauf que personne ne dit claude écoles
s'est pas uniquement martinique puis en
guadeloupe n'eût-il isin utilisés adopté
mais malheureusement barreau la bourse
pour moi tu es un malheureusement on y
reviendra
floriane merci d'avancé sur la tête dans
son caddie on rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fidh et soir
[Musique]